what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking thrones today I'm hoping
and praying that this video will play
properly for everybody that wants to
watch it still for the first time most
of you have probably watched this
Melisandre video already but for some
strange reason there was a glitch after
I uploaded this video about a week ago
it worked perfectly fine for about 10
hours then all of a sudden the video
would just stop playing in its entirety
somehow this video went from being 14
minutes long to 16 seconds long I've got
a ton of comments from some of you
asking me why this video was only 16
seconds long but I didn't have a good
answer for you because I had no idea why
I emailed YouTube and I asked them and
they still haven't responded to me but
since so many of you asked me to reload
this so you can watch it I figured I
would upload it again and hope that it
works for those of you that weren't able
to watch it when it was originally
uploaded I tried to download the video
from my own YouTube page but when I
downloaded it from my page it was still
only 16 seconds long but thankfully
somebody actually stole my video and
uploaded it to their own page and they
were lucky enough to have the full
original video so I actually had to
download my own video that you are
watching now from another channel that
stole my video people are always
downloading my videos in their entirety
then uploading them to their own
channels to profit but this is the one
time that I was actually happy somebody
stole my video because it allowed me to
have my original fourteen-minute version
again I apologize for the rambling about
this but I know some of you asked me
about this so I just wanted to clarify a
few things also I just want to mention
real quick before the video starts I am
doing a new giveaway and I will be
giving away three different prizes to
three different winners this month so if
you haven't entered the giveaway yet the
link will be done in the description I
will be giving away the complete
collection of the Song of Ice and Fire
novels and I'm giving away the world of
Ice and Fire novel and the Game of
Thrones Monopoly game if you are
interested in winning one of these
prizes make sure you follow the link
down below because there are five
different ways you can enter to increase
your chances of winning but let's get
the video started
I would only be a distraction if I
stayed so where will you go
volantis good if you don't mind my
saying I don't think you should return
to west dress I'm not sure you'd be safe
here I will return there spider
one last time your lady I have to die in
this strange country when I made my
video about Arya Starks hit list I
talked about whether or not we would see
Melisandre again because she was on
arias hit list for taking Gendry away to
perform her blood magic
and according to Melisandre she did say
that her and Arya wouldn't meet again I
see a darkness in you
and in that darkness eyes staring back
at me brown eyes blue eyes green eyes
eyes you'll shut forever
we will meet again I think there is a
very good chance they can still meet
again but I don't necessarily think that
means it would be the death of
Melisandre or at least not right away
after I started thinking about what
Melisandre is role could be in season 8
I ended up going back and watching
pretty much every one of her scenes to
look for any more possible clues that
might indicate how she can still be of
some use as we all know the Great War
for the dawn is upon us and now that the
night king is south of the wall it's
just a matter of time before he starts
killing everyone in Westeros and adding
them to his army of the dead as of right
now the night King just brought down the
wall at eastwatch-by-the-sea and he is
making his way south as Jon and Daenerys
are making their way to white Harbor
where they will then travel north to
Winterfell where they can possibly meet
face to face with the night king once
again Jon and Daenerys know they do not
have what it takes to defeat the night
king with what they have that's the main
reason why they even went to the dragon
pit to try and get the support from
Cersei to provide her Lannister soldiers
for the great war but we all know Cersei
isn't going to even help them and not
only that she says she has 20,000 men
from the golden company coming from
Essos as her reinforcements John was
able to rally the north behind him in
season six but they don't have as many
soldiers as they once did and we still
don't know how they are going to react
when John shows up what Daenerys
Targaryen which is someone most of the
northerners hate considering all the bad
blood they've had from the past so we
could possibly see some of the
northerners turned their back on Jon
Snow I'm not saying that's gonna happen
but I'm just saying it could happen
Daenerys is providing her own solid into
three key soldiers to help John but we
aren't sure how they will be able to
adapt to the conditions in the north
the Dothraki are outstanding fighters in
the open field but they have only fought
in much warmer climates so how good will
they be when the ground is frozen and
covered in snow and the temperatures are
freezing cold as they try to fight
across the northern terrain I don't
think they're gonna fare as well as they
did during the spoils of war
Daenerys only has two dragons left as
well and we have seen just how easily
they can be taken out of the sky with
just one blow from the making spear
not to mention Daenerys said the night
King has around 100,000 White's in his
army I'm not really sure how she came up
with that number but she did have a
bird's-eye view when she went up north
drogon so maybe she could give an
accurate estimation there's a very good
chance that John and Daenerys can't win
this war with what they have the night
king has a dragon he has Giants and he
possibly has 100,000 White's who are all
built to fight in the snow plus they
still have to worry about Cersei she
still has Lannister soldiers plus Euron
in his fleet that is about to be filled
with 20,000 men from the golden company
I think in order for John and Daenerys
to win both of these wars they're gonna
need some kind of an x-factor some kind
of outside force that no one would see
coming which leads me to Melisandre
Melisandre could possibly be the key to
adding some kind of balance to this
great war this is a song of ice and fire
and that title describes more than just
one thing it has been a theme throughout
this entire series and it's going to
play its biggest part in the end of this
series - the night king has a direct
connection to ice he can actually
manipulate the ice into powerful weapons
that can take down a dragon with one
strike so we may need something that can
manipulate the fire side of things and
create a type of weapon that the knight
King cannot stop some might say we
already have that weapon with the
Dragons but I think it's gonna take even
more than that I don't think the dragons
are gonna be the ultimate weapon in the
end
Melisandre also has that direct
connection to fire she can actually see
things in the flames and she can even
manipulate fire - which could be just
some tricks but it could be more than
that and she knows she's going to be
needed in this great war she even said
as much to Jon Snow the last time that
they spoke I've been ready to die for
many years if the Lord was done with me
so be it but he's not you've seen the
night King Jon Snow
you know with the Great War still to
come you know the army of the Dead will
be upon us soon and you know I can help
you win that war she told John that he
knows she can help him win this war but
the question is how what else can
Melisandre do or provide to help John
win this war at this point I think
Melisandre must have some other kind of
hidden power that we have yet to see her
use when she first met Jon back when he
was the Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch she did say something enters
thing to him that may possibly reveal
exactly what she means by being able to
help him still do you feel my heart
beating this power in you you resist it
and that's your mistake embraces the
Lord of light made us male and female
two parts of a greater room you're not
joining his power power to make life
power to make light power to cast
shadows think about what she actually
said right there to John
she asked John if he could feel her
heart beating as his hand was on her
chest she said that he has power within
him but he resists that power he needs
to embrace that power
Melisandre knew that John had King's
blood which is why she said together
they can make life make light and cast
shadows since John has King's blood Mel
could use him to make another shadow
baby just like she did what Stannis when
they use this power to kill Renly
Baratheon
when Melisandre says she can help John
win this war maybe she thinks that they
can make another shadow baby together
and use it to kill the night king but
what I found even more interesting in
what she said to John right there was
together they can make light now what do
you think she means when she says they
can make light together could that
possibly be another reference to light
bringer Melisandre has always been a big
believer that azor Ahai or the prince
that was promised would be the one to
defeat the darkness using a flaming
sword called light bringer azor Ahai is
a legendary figure who many believed was
the man who forged a hero's sword by
plunging it into the chest of Nissa
Nissa which caused it to catch fire in
combining with Nissa Nissa soul it
created the sword Lightbringer
when azor Ahai created light bringer
Nissa Nissa had to bear her breast first
which is exactly what Melisandre did
with John in that scene Melisandre asked
him if he could feel her heart beating
that could be some foreshadowing that
Jon will need to plunge it into
Melisandre chest to create Lightbringer
Melisandre said they could create light
together so maybe this is the light that
she is referring to the legendary
flaming sword
we got a demonstration of this on the
beats of Dragonstone back in season two
in the ancient books it's written that a
warrior will draw a burning sword from
the fire
and that sword shall be Lightbringer if
you continue watching on the screen you
can see Stannis actually pull the sword
from the chest of a burning statue but
as we all know Stannis was not the one
which Melisandre later admitted but now
she believes John is the one and she may
have realized that you need an actual
living person to sacrifice themselves in
order to form Lightbringer and
Melisandre might know that the person
that needs to be sacrificed is actually
her and John is gonna need to be the one
to plunge his sword into her bare chest
and not just some statues on a beach
Melisandre has always said that death by
fire is the purest death and I think it
would be fitting if Melisandre actually
died by fire too what better way to
sacrifice herself in order for this to
happen
considering she has sacrificed so many
people force of mere said great power
requires great sacrifice this could be
why Melisandre knows she has to come
back to Westeros and die Melisandre said
she's going to volantis but she will be
back because she has to die in this
country just like Varys I talked about
Daenerys being nice and Issa before but
now that I think about it I think there
is a much stronger case for it being
Melisandre in the show at least if
they're gonna bring Melisandre back to
this country and kill her off it has to
be in some epic fashion and I think her
sacrificing herself in order for the
knight King to finally be stopped would
be a very fitting way to end her story
she has been preaching about the prince
who was promised for many seasons now
and they keep showing us these burning
swords so I think it would make a lot of
sense if Melisandre was the one who had
to bare her breasts one last time for
John to plunge his sword into her making
the steel combined with her soul to
create Lightbringer they also showed
Gilly reading a page straight out of a
world of Ice and Fire and it was
actually about azor Ahai and when Sam
got the Winter foe he told brand that he
knew John was going to be the one to
lead the fight against the night king so
I would be very disappointed if we
didn't get some kind of payoff to the
azure Ahai prophecy after they have been
hyping it up for years but this is just
my opinion there is another way
Melisandre could possibly help and I
think she might have hinted at this when
she met Daenerys in the throne room on
Dragonstone listen carefully to what
Melisandre actually says to Daenerys
right here the Lord of Light doesn't
have many followers in Westeros does he
not yes but even those who don't worship
the Lord can serve his cause
Daenerys said the Lord of Light doesn't
have many followers in Westeros but
Melisandre said not yet which makes me
think more are about to arrive which
could be another reason why Melisandre
left for volantis the followers aren't
here yet because Melisandre is going to
get them now this all depends on what
the show decides to include in their
version of this story but in volantis
where Melisandre is going there is a
group of slave soldiers called the fury
hand and they're the ones who guard the
red temple / allure in the free city of
volantis there is a high priest at this
temple named Bernard who is a strong
supporter of Daenerys in the books but
in the show I believe they actually gave
this role to kin Varro who was the High
Priestess that Tyrion brought to murine
when Tyrion met what can Vora he said he
was going to try and persuade her into
supporting Daenerys but can vara cut him
off and said he doesn't need to persuade
her because she already believes that
Daenerys is the chosen one the princess
who was promised and we have still yet
to get any kind of closure what can vara
yet and now that Melisandre is going to
volantis there is a strong possibility
that they team up together and come back
to Westeros with some kind of plan or
even a force of the fury hand as far as
I can remember the fury hand only
consists of about a thousand men never
more never less but this could be a nice
addition to help in this war against the
knight king one cool thing about these
soldiers are their weapons they use
Spears that have a flame on the end of
them the exact opposite of what the
knight King and the White Walkers use
can you imagine seeing the White Walkers
and the men of the fury hand running
into battle at each other one side with
ice Spears in the other side with fire
Spears I think that would look pretty
badass in my opinion plus it would be
kind of cool having the knight King on
one side of the battlefield and having
Melisandre and can vara and whoever else
they bring with them on the other side
of the battlefield we could see people
being risen from the dead on both sides
fire white sand ice whites I would love
to see the look on the night Kings face
if he saw someone else bringing someone
back from the dead it will probably turn
him on and have him thinking that needs
to be his Nights queen someone else who
has the power to raise the dead who
knows but things can get very
interesting if we get to see the red
guard show its true strength during this
war for the dawn but before I go too far
down tinfoil' road let me just send this
video right here I want to thank all of
you for watching today's video I
appreciate that as always and I hope to
see you all come back for the next one I
also want to thank the supporters of
this channel from patreon have a great
day everyone I will see you down in the
comment section bye